so  when it comes to divorce um women file  for divorce seventy percent of the time  that's and college educated women it's  ninety percent  second thing is um  twenty percent of men have access to  eighty percent of women so the reason  that women think all men are players is  because they're all sleeping with the  same one proud to be part of that  so one in three men under 30 are virgins  so so for me right i'm five eleven and a  half i'm close to six foot right i  prefer guys my height or taller right or  close to my height but let's say i  wanted six foot or taller i'm six  o'clock  um that that's only fifteen percent of  guys on top of that if you have a  specific type so  you've got a small category right so and  let's say i want a guy that makes more  money than i do and is more driven than  i am that's an even smaller percentage  the reason like women think men are  players is because we're all sleeping  with the same ones